do you do you like drinking tea tea yeah
yeah I was gonna ask if you would just
like to have a conversation with me and
have some tea okay yeah you're done very
cool
[Music]
so here's your tea and here's a straw
thanks you're welcome what was your name
um Damien or Ty well I'll call you Ty
okay and my name is thoriah I don't know
if you are right yeah all right so well
first of all how are you doing really
I'm like really tired and drained and
now I have to go all the way to
Massachusetts after this so I'm just
like uh just kind of kind of sucks why
do you have to go to Massachusetts uh I
recently joined the military because I
was just like
nothing's going on with my life and I I
feel like I'm really not a school person
right now so at least with this I can do
school instead of four years I could
possibly do it over the course of six
which I just thought about I'm like
that's six years of school do you have
any regrets on joining it
some one is that I used to have lots of
hair
um oh really yeah we used to have locks
I used to come down to here and they cut
them because you know that's just not
something you can have I felt like I
definitely did look more handsome with
them I was like I looked myself in the
room I'm like God damn like this is not
gonna look good on the gram you look
handsome now too thank you I don't know
what you look like before but so that's
one of your the reasons you regret
joining it yeah that's one of them yeah
I only joined when I wasn't I like a
good state of mind so it was just kind
of like I gotta
do something it's like a really old
school drill because I only heard this
from my older people but it's like uh
you only joined the military when you
have nothing better to do I was like
damn it really got like that like I was
sitting in like I was sitting in a boot
camp around like
damn it was kind of right what's what's
something I wouldn't believe about you
probably that I joined the military
like if I didn't tell you that like
would you believe me
um if I hadn't been doing my film
Project I've been doing this for five
years so I've met a lot of people and
I'm just
come to terms with do you really never
know and also I live in San Diego which
is like a pretty big like military town
oh are you just visiting yourself no
you're fine so I meet a lot of young
people who you wouldn't think
are in the military but they actually
are so that's the only reason why I
personally but I see how the general
public would be shocked by that without
you you know what I'm saying yeah
um so why do you think that people
wouldn't believe that about you I don't
know I'm not I'm not really that tough
and I'm also like a very emotional
person which
yeah you know like they'll they'll
really get you but it's kind of just
like at a certain point it's just like
all right shut up I get it I'm emotional
I gotta figure out how to not come
across as like being a pain in the butt
to everyone while also getting across my
message like hey don't
don't come at me like that like and it's
very weird because I I don't have very
good social skills really you seem like
you do
I can fake it I'm an only child but also
I didn't really have like a lot of
cousins around me either so I was like
really an only child I really only had
like my mom and like my aunts and my
grandmother it just kind of sucked
so you feel like the impacted you like
socially
yeah although you have like you know
friends you kind of just basically like
you're going at it but just just with
just yourself you know I feel like I
don't really have like very good
anything skills right now I lost a lot
of my creativity when I kind of just
like gave up a while ago like I remember
before I would have like a lot of ideas
and like my like my brain used to work
in like a very like a really nice way
that I used to like and now it's kind of
just like
I don't know I feel like really flat my
brain just doesn't work the same way
that it used to and it kind of just
makes me sad you know it's like all
those shows where it's like oh don't
lose your you know Edge or like using
creativity and it was like damn like
they got to me bro I'm not just saying
this to make you feel better about it
like creativity comes in seasons and
like sometimes for me it almost feels
like my brain needs to shut down for a
while let me ask you this do you think
there there was a reason why it stopped
or
um I don't know I think that's probably
when I started getting like really sad
about like just everything you know like
I changed from like the way that I used
to be and like I don't know I just don't
enjoy the same things like I don't feel
the same way about certain things and
it's like I started eating tomatoes
while I was gone I was like damn like I
like tomatoes now like that's crazy it's
really weird because I felt like that
was a new low for me it was like damn
I'm eating tomatoes I used to hate
Tomatoes I used to be like what the
they're in the middle of my sandwich
that's I still feel like that about
pickles I'll never like pickles what's
the most beautiful thing you've ever
seen
this one thing has been making me feel
like really like emotional recently it's
like
if you know anything about Pokemon does
this one Pokemon called mimic you and it
literally like puts on a costume of
Pikachu just because he wants to be
loved and he can't touch other things
because his touch is like deadly
okay it's like I don't know it's just
like it made me really sad like I was
like sitting and they were like it just
sucks
so you can't touch anything he can't he
can't touch other people because his
touch is deadly not deadly but like it
makes people sick and like his
appearance is like really scary oh yeah
I know right that's what I was saying it
was like that's that's so unfair and
like people he was like he literally
like literally a part of his design and
that he dresses up as another Pokemon
that people like so that people will
like him
I was like
so when he dresses up as other Pokemons
then can he touch people not really
still not but like he looks like this
and like his real eyes are down here
that's how he looks when he's trying to
look like Pikachu yeah they haven't
released what he looks like underneath
it they don't we don't know
that is so sad it is
what's your biggest insecurity
I don't know I guess like being you're
good bro
I see white Air Forces just like me I
like them when they're worn out really I
like them when they're like a little bit
crazy that's yeah on guys I like them
crispy on girls I like them more now
really yeah oh man
because on guys it almost feels like you
just need a new pair
but on the girls it's like oh like
that's cool like she doesn't care how
she looks I get what you mean sometimes
I would buy bands and I would literally
throw dirt on them no that hurts my
heart but I feel like everybody fans are
worn out like I don't I don't think I've
ever seen a good pair of hands exactly
you should never see a good pair of
pants we're just like looking at
everyone's shoes out there walking by I
am now the question yeah
I said that being completely seen for
like who you are I feel like sometimes
people see more about me than I can see
about them and that's kind of like odd I
think like a bit ago I had like a
partner where like they knew a lot about
me and I felt like I didn't know as much
about them even though like I feel like
I definitely try to and it's like like
how do you like how do you find these
things out about me like you know you
try to find out some more about a person
like naturally and it's just like I
don't know how to do that you know you
think it's more of like you're unable to
get to know the person and not that
you're more open than them and maybe I
don't know I don't know which one it is
like it kind of just flip back and forth
between that but like and so that scares
you that like maybe getting close to
someone that you're more vulnerable than
they are because they know you more okay
I feel like that sucks like being more
vulnerable than someone else
yeah so what happened what ended up
happening with that relationship you
guys did you break up because of that it
wasn't because of that but that was a
contributing factor
can you describe to us your perfect day
all right I got to spend more time with
myself because I have no clue
um
I'm not sure I'd say like
I kind of just want to feel like at
peace because like I feel like there's
always like a thousand and one things
like running through my head all the
time so it's kind of
like I wanted to be able to you know
actually you know get rid of them I
think I'm always just like very anxious
and like I think it like stems from like
you know ADHD and stuff so it's like I'm
pretty sure like I'm like I'm just like
always anxious about something like and
it doesn't even matter what it is so
it's like I don't know I feel like I
just haven't had a break from it oh that
person's tattoos are so cool
you can't see all of them but like the
ones on our other armor look so cool
yeah
it's a part of the project people
walking through those are dope pants I
know exactly what I'd wear with those
with those pants yeah with them I have
like these uh oh man you could probably
look them up they're like they're called
Bordeaux 12s how do you spell that you
got those not the 12s oh those
I don't like admitting that I'm really
into like fashion and like outfits
because I feel like a lot of people take
that as being materialistic but I really
think it's like an art like to like find
a right outfit you know what I'm saying
it genuinely is I feel like I think of
like
technically everything's in art in my
opinion because like you can be the
master at something that nobody cares
about but if you're the master at it
then holy nobody's ever going to beat
you at it like
this is the same thing I wore the other
day I just watched it well not the shirt
but like the pants and the sneakers it's
just easier because it's like all right
I know I won't look a fool if I walk out
in this it's like your safe outfit yeah
yeah I've been wearing this outfit for
three days it'd be like that
I'll just be like all right how many
people saw me in this like it'll be like
the people in my neighborhood I'm like
as every as soon as I get out my
neighborhood I'm safe but it's like the
people in my neighborhood don't need to
know this I know the people in the lobby
of our hotel are probably like why is
this girl wearing this thing and it's
like a unique outfit too so it's like
they obviously know where yeah oh man
see I'm safe because it's just like you
know sweatpants and like and so it's
like all right I could just pretend this
got way off topic I just thought about
that what song lyric reminds you of
someone
there's this one song and I don't
remember the name of it but it's by this
like Creator called Eli so straight he
says something like sometimes I feel
like you gave up like you had your mind
made up and I was like damn that kind of
does suck and it's like you know
sometimes it feels like
before some like before someone like
really gives up on something like they
already have their mind made up and so
it's like like there's a big lead up to
giving up on something yeah
it kind of does remind me of someone I
was just like
I don't know I kind of don't understand
I'm kind of scared you don't have to all
right you want me to go into the next
question yeah maybe you're too young to
be this stressed you're 20. yeah that's
true but it's kind of just like it's
whatever at this point I think you
shouldn't accept it I think you could
find peace I don't know if you work on
it and don't give up that's true you
know some days it's like damn I don't
want to have to wait till I'm 25 to be
happy you know yeah what does happiness
look like for you just like being at
peace I don't know just whatever this
isn't
like I know there's nothing I can say to
make you feel better yeah I think that's
what I'm struggling with
no I think that's perfect I think that's
like a normal reaction because like I
get I feel like that sometimes too where
it's like I want to make someone feel
better but it's like there's nothing you
can do so it's kind of just like that
yeah
like
like I don't know what to do man so
were you gonna say something no I was
just looking at the birdie at the
Cracker because he's like trying really
hard but he just that's something he
does not realize he can't get it up it's
just like yeah little chunks off yeah
like he tried to pick it up like four
times and then he gave up and started
doing that oh he's trying to fly away
with it he did and then it's just like
you know he keeps picking it up every
couple seconds like maybe I could try
now like no you still can't do it but
sorry it's like half the size
I know he's doing his best I was
literally thinking that in the back of
my head he's trying he I think he's like
nibbling parts off to maybe eventually
be able to fly away with it I feel like
this is a metaphor for Life what
can we make of this
oh he has a friend his friend's gonna
help him oh that's the third one oh
there's four of them holy crap oh
well yeah right
it's not what you thought it was the
haters I feel like I can't continue this
interview until I see this bird fly with
it yeah it's kind of like it's like
bothering me it's like damn like I keep
looking over there
should we go like chop it up for him oh
okay did he go into crack
okay
you missed it
didn't even missed it I missed it he's
up there now look
he flew away with it it's not there
anymore you know I think I was meant to
see your reaction
and he got the crackers I mean not have
to feel the concrete on my mother
I should have brought like a little
thing you could sit on don't even worry
about it okay Ty I feel like we're best
friends now all right but let's go when
you picture your dream future what does
it look like
it's weird because I haven't really
pictured a feature for myself
um I don't know I feel like I kind of
was just like I don't know I didn't
think I'd get this far
I don't really have anything that I
really want from life right now I'm kind
of just like I
I know what I don't want you know what I
mean like I feel like that's like a lot
of stuff in life too it's like I kind of
just know what I don't want or like
I know how I don't want to feel but I
don't really have anything that I want
um
so it's like
I don't know
[Music]
can I put it here
oh my God am I see
wait I don't know where it came from are
you feeling for real or is this like a
joke no I'm not kidding is this a part
of this
part of it
there's no this is definitely a part of
it I don't know where it came from
did you turn on the other one yeah
I don't know you look too desperate to
have not I mean it definitely this is
definitely a part of it maybe you should
open it and see what it is oh my God it
is I'm like
how could I have put that there though
uh
okay
how did you write this throughout the
entire what
it was not me that's what I'm telling
you it's just magic there's nothing it's
just the world set that up somehow
read it to me because I don't know okay
it says
this is so embarrassing no
you're such a kind of Ty you are such a
kind and comforting Soul you may not
feel as if you know yourself or your
purpose but there is so much
authenticity and how you speak and
interact with those around you
self-discovery happens from both the
inside and out for the inside spend more
time with yourself and find out who you
are and be that person in every place
you go and everything you do like
everything else mastering who you are is
an art so pay attention to your thoughts
all 1000 and one of them embrace your
emotions regardless of if they are
embraced by others find peace in who you
already are and not in who you would
become if you were to change in the ways
you were led to believe you should for
the uh hopefully this 300 can help you
find your style and share who you are
with the world again who you are as an
art like your style be the way you
express it love the universe
that's so kind of you it's so kind of
the universe
well the universe led me here so that's
true I think we were meant to meet huh
that was so crazy how you actually had
like a real face like like you gave it
away but you look so drained when we
were like
I don't know
I gave it away on purpose because you
looked concerned I did I was like am I
like a secret agent I love your reaction
I have one last question for you though
okay uh why do you think we met
um I'm not sure
I'm not sure oh do you have to go soon
huh what do you mean I don't know it
sounds like I feel like this is like a
thing that you do like at the end of the
interview so I was like kind of sad I
was like no oh no ah but it sucks that
the interview's over and I'm saying I'm
like oh damn like I should have did
better oh you did great I'm not I know
you don't take compliments you think
they're fake but
I swear on my life like you did so good
yeah you're very like genuine and it's
very refreshing to meet people like you
really I'm being totally honest you're
like really sweet and kind and I don't I
know you want to change but I hope you I
hope you change for the whatever to to
like progress in life yeah but I really
hope that you also don't change in a lot
of ways because yeah is there any like
is there any other questions you have
like one that's not like written down
like do you have anything you want to
ask oh that's it you're putting me on
the spot here yeah you put me on the
spot
I guess I want some reassurance that
you'll be okay yeah I mean like it just
you know sometimes just sucks to be in
like that one place but it's like it's
whatever like
you know it'd be like that sometimes
sorry
do you want to hug it out oh yeah all
right thank you so much
hi everyone I'll be posting bonus
footage on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
I'll have it linked in my description
thank you guys for watching I love you
all and I'll see you next time